(upbeat music)
- I just think that you should think
that every decision is right.
And I think most people think
every decision is wrong.
- Hmm.
- Like most people just go into
did I make the right decision?
There's just this unbelievable
ability to beat oneself up,
to be cynical, to be
pessimistic, to be fear based,
and I'm just trying to
get people to flip it
because, life is actually how
it plays out in your head.
It just actually is, like, my ability
to turn every negative into
a positive is very real.
And I watched many people taking positives
and turning into
negatives, it's very real.
Life is a perspective game and we need
to have more positive optimism, the end.
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
You got your perspective.
Just wanna be happy, don't
you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
I am ready to get into it,
so Gus, if you wanna get
the first question going
here, I am ready to go.
Big shout out to Brandon
Britton who's with us.
There we go!
Leon, what is good, my man?
Good morning.
- Hey Gary, good morning.
Yeah, good to be on
with you, have some tea?
- Thank you, love it.
- Yeah, so, yeah, my question
is, what do you think
a number three or number
four person in the business
should look like in terms of
putting themselves out there
and getting themselves known?
Because, I'm in a bit
of that spot right now
where I'm falling out of love
of social media coaching for businesses.
So I'm just trying to
switch myself out of that.
- And you know, for everybody's watching
who doesn't understand
what Leon's referring to,
what you've heard from me Leon is,
hey, there's a lot of people
that can be great number twos,
threes, fours, five, six, sevens,
who could quote unquote, make more money
being a number six at VaynerMedia
than they would have as being a number one
in whatever hustle or business
that they've started for themselves.
And so you're saying
you've been doing coaching
and consulting and things of that nature,
and now you want to produce
content to give you leverage
to be hired as a number three or four?
- Yeah, I think so.
I feel that way because I've
been trying to do it myself
and like, I don't like to enjoy--
- You don't enjoy it enough.
- Yeah, like, I don't get up
excited every morning about it,
you know what I mean?
- I totally get it.
And I think, you know,
it's one of the things
that I'm talking about,
that I'm most proud of,
because I'm trying to create
permission and self awareness,
to not have to be an
entrepreneur in a world where
if you're under 40, you almost
feels like you have to be.
Which is crazy, it's almost become like,
entrepreneurship almost become
like school and college,
Everyone thinks you have to.
- Hmm.
- So a couple things.
The first thing I'd probably do is
make a list of the 25 businesses
and 25 entrepreneurs you most admire,
if you can even make a list that big.
Because, one of the
things you can consider is
spending a couple of weeks just
analyzing those businesses.
Obviously, if you've been an entrepreneur,
or doing your own thing,
it's likely for you
to be a three and four
in probably a company
that's probably between
50, 25 maybe to 100 people.
You're not gonna go be
number three or four
at Amazon, or Netflix, or BMW.
- Yeah.
- Right?
So, you probably wanna
focus on the entrepreneur,
in the sector that you most enjoy.
And then there's two things to do.
One, you really analyze their business,
and you start putting out
content about Manny's pizza shop,
or VaynerMedia or, you know,
whatever the company is.
You start actually making
content like, literally like
analyzing their social media and saying,
you know, literally on
LinkedIn, the title is,
you know, three things I see
The Grapefruit Shop can fix
on social media, literally.
So that's one way.
The other way is, to
literally write an email to,
you know, "Dear Sally Thompson.
"I've admired your business
from afar for a long time.
"I love video game, you know, tchotchkes
"and you do it better than anybody else.
"Let me just tell you a
little bit about myself.
"If there's anything I
can ever do pro bono,
"please let me know."
That's one version, that's asking.
The other version is the email
that is similar to the blog post,
"Dear Sally Pace,
"you know, have always loved
your esports trinket business,
"you know, with Corona, I've
had some time on my hands.
"I spent the last half a
week analyzing your social.
"Below are seven things
"that I would highly
recommend you pay attention to
"that can make your social
media profile better."
No ask, no anything, just like,
"Thank you so much.
"If there's anything I can ever
help you with in the future,
"please hit me back.
"Love you, Leon."
Those three tactics against the human
are the things that will work.
- Cool, all right.
Yeah.
- Awesome.
- Thanks man.
- I appreciate you, Leon.
Get on it.
First, figure out who you admire.
It's okay to take a month right now
and try to consume a ton of entrepreneurs
and a ton of small businesses.
Where do you live?
- In Montreal in Canada.
- Love it.
There's a lot of
interesting creative stuff
going on in Montreal.
If you don't want to leave that area,
you should really do homework.
- Thanks man.
- Homework, you got me.
- Yeah, I'm gonna be going
into the vegan market.
- Love that, that's where your passion is?
- Yeah, I'm really
interested in that stuff
and I'm putting out more
content about food and chefs--
- There's a ton of vegan startups,
direct to consumer vegan
brands, that I'm sure
your social media consulting
and coaching can help.
Is similar to where I told
you to audit their page
and then DM them or email them.
- Ask them.
- Take care, buddy.
- You too.
- Yeah, of course, Leon.
If you are on and sharing,
there we go, David.
Hendon Sangwell, very good job.
Kim Nunley, very good.
I'm gonna share you Kim and
give you the follow boom, Kim.
The big fucking follow for Kim.
Nate Gaines, big follow for him.
Nate, I am now your 882nd follower.
Hello, my man.
- Hi.
First off, I want to say thank you.
You brought a lot of good content
and even though I haven't
needed to follow it
for like two years, I've been
consuming it for two years,
and it's very motivating and all that.
- Thank you.
What's your name, my friend?
- I'm Kon.
- Kon, and where you from?
- Yeah.
I was born in Greece
but, I've grown up in Australia
since I was like three.
- I love it.
Nice to meet you, Kon.
- Thank you, nice to meet you too.
Okay, so is it all right
if I give some content,
context first before my question?
- It is.
- Sorry, I'm a little bit nervous.
- Don't worry.
- I'll eventually get
around my words.
- I'm sure, go ahead.
- So, pretty much I'm in my
second year of university,
the course one is college, you guys know.
I'm doing sports and exercise science.
And my goal is that eventually
I want to work in high performance sport.
Recently, I started, about a month ago,
I started branding myself a lot more,
I started my Instagram started my,
I've got a website now,
LinkedIn and all that.
And pretty much I want to share who I am,
what I'm learning and all that.
But, what I've been wondering
is just how I can provide more valuable
considering that I am a younger,
more inexperienced coach?
'Cause, I see all of the content
that other more experienced
people are putting out
it's like, I don't know where
my place is really, you know?
- Your place is in
hypotheses and opinions.
Because, what you don't have
is experience yet, right?
And you don't have the leverage
of results from athletes, right?
And so you're in a very similar place
to where I was when I first
walked into the Wine Library,
which was, I had ideas,
I'm sure you have ideas
of an hypotheses and opinions,
but right now, to your point,
you know, where a lot of 22 year olds,
20 year olds, 18 year olds get caught,
is they think only expertise
can bring leverage to business.
And what they end up doing is
they fake it until they make it
and they start talking about shit
that they don't know about.
And, what I mean by that
is, it's one thing, Kon,
if you say, "Hey",
if your video is
literally like this, "Hey,
"you know, I can't wait to
eventually try out this thesis.
"But, something that's been on my mind
"is if people use ice and
heat three hours before
"or, if they," you know,
I would share ideas.
A, most people don't like to share ideas
'cause they think people will steal them,
and, I don't think people understand
that the world is abundant, plus,
if you put it out on the internet first,
it's almost like you own it,
it can't really necessarily be stolen.
Number two, you don't have
any other choice, Kon.
Until you have, you know clients,
until you have 15 years
of experience, you don't.
And so the thing that
you have to do for sure,
there's a lot of things
that you don't have to do.
But the one thing you have to do
is be very careful not to make things up
or fake it till you make
it, I see this every day.
20 year old life coaches, 20
year old this, 20 year old that
and they just, and I understand,
I've empathy for them.
They're just kind of
almost lying, bullshitting,
embellishing, tricking
to seem like an authority
when they're not.
And that will never work in the end.
It might work short term,
you might get something out
of it in the short term,
but long term, you always get exposed.
So, for me, what you need to
do is document the journey
of becoming who you're gonna become.
And that's more talking
about frustrations,
talking about trying out some
theories on your friends,
'cause real athletes won't let you,
talking about ideas you
have, doing green screen,
you know, how I have this
green screen right now,
this T-setup, you know,
you do it, you know, how you see on TikTok
people making content over
other people's videos?
Maybe you start sharing your opinions
on other people's videos.
There's a lot of ways
you could go about it.
But the number one mistake,
the common mistake,
the thing I see 90% of time
of kids in this position,
they start making up shit,
and they always will get caught on that.
- Well, I think what
you're saying makes sense,
and I think that it would be good
just like even going forward,
just having a backlog
of this is what I've done,
this is what I say, like, what
you're saying makes sense.
I think the other bit that I get caught on
is if I should even be
bothering trying to share
and trying to promote myself now--
- 100%, you should, I'll tell you why.
- Would you...
Okay.
- Because one day you're gonna be 81,
and it's gonna be so powerful that video,
for your 16 year old great grandson.
- Yeah.
So you think that's worth it still
'cause the place I'm coming from is just--
- Kon.
- I don't know if it's, yeah?
- It's worth it for you, the human being,
maybe not worth it for you,
the business sports business side yet.
- Yeah.
- You will be, you know how,
I'm at my parents' house.
Do you know how sad I am,
I don't have pictures of
me at baseball card shows?
- Yeah.
- I'm devastated, I wish I had them.
I wish I had pictures of
me at the lemonade stand,
I wish I had a video of me,
washing cars, shoveling snow.
The reason you need to do it
is for your great grandchildren
and for yourself one day to look back on,
not to convert business, you understand?
- Yeah, no, that makes sense.
- And by the way, what if God willing
you become one of the great
players in your field,
and they have to make a
documentary about you?
The video will be really
good for the documentary.
- Yeah.
- Plus take it from me--
- that's one way to look--
- One day, you're not
gonna have that much hair.
So it'd be nice to have
video with that much hair.
Yeah, Kon--
- That's it.
- Think of it in the
macro, not in the micro.
- Yeah, okay.
That makes sense--
- And real quick, one last thing.
- Yeah.
- And, God willing by accident,
you make you may make one video
that resonates with
millions of people, why not?
- Yeah.
Yeah, okay, that makes sense, yeah,
'cause I think the thing is, I enjoy it.
It's just, I was having trouble
justifying it to myself.
- Great, because if you enjoy it,
I just gave you very clear,
black and white justifications.
- Yeah, okay.
Can I ask one more quick question?
- Please.
- Going off of the document
of the correct kind of thing
that you're saying that
I should be following.
Regarding LinkedIn, what I currently do is
I only post when I get a longer form post,
like a blog post on my blog,
and then I share that to LinkedIn also.
Do you think that just shorter form like,
this is what I've done this week?
- Try it, try it.
- Okay
- Try it, I'm not sure but try it.
- Okay.
- The answer, what's
great about the internet
and that everybody fucks up is trying it
and getting back the
feedback after 10 times
of doing the short thing,
so what I did this week,
and it's not working is more valuable
than debating it or asking an expert.
- Yeah, okay.
Thank you so much.
- Okay.
Take care my friend.
- I really appreciate this.
- Happy to do it.
- Thank you, bye.
- Bye bye.
All right, let's go back
to Twitter before we go.
There's Amanda Lambert.
Amanda, you get a follow,
Amanda I'm your 150th follower.
Remy, my good friend
Remy is in the building.
Sandra Fowler, it's time
for Sandra to get a follow.
She's such a hardcore community member.
Devin Alexander is always
in the mix, I love that.
Hi, Leslie.
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- Good, I've been following
you for a long time,
so this is really exciting to talk to you.
- Thank you, where are you from?
- I'm from Florida, so
Gainesville, Florida.
- Awesome.
- So my question to you is, I mean,
just a little background, I'm
a branding and web designer.
Most of my clients are, they're
kind of all over the world.
Most of them are creatives,
probably 70% photographers,
the rest, creatives,
artists, things like that.
I've been doing this
for, coming on 12 years.
So, I feel like my business
is in a good place--
- So you started when you were six?
- I'm actually 36 years old, I look 12.
- That's good.
- Yeah, it'll help when I'm 50, so.
- Go ahead.
- So I have 12 years experience.
I feel like I have a
lot of value to offer,
but I just, I love what I do so much,
that I'm always like, I'm
hearing all these voices of like,
"Oh, you should do a
course or to offer value."
And I know there's a lot I can offer,
but, I just love what I do,
and I don't wanna do anything else.
I feel like--
- Good news, you've won.
- Yeah.
But, I feel like am I doing a disjustice
to other designers that
I can teach things.
Like, I just don't feel
like doing a whole course.
- I don't think that
that's really necessarily
where your energy is coming from,
it's probably coming from your
logical entrepreneurial
brain and other voices
that you're leaving money on the table.
- Yeah.
- Not that, you're not helping.
If that's the case, you
wouldn't sell course.
Like for example, my great want,
what's pulling at my heartstrings is
to be the most helpful
entrepreneur to other entrepreneurs
in the history of entrepreneurship,
which is why I don't have
masterminds and courses,
it's why I put out everything for free.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right?
So, I think to your point,
and I can feel the energy.
You know that there are some
business opportunity there,
it's more "scalable," but
you just don't give a shit
and good news, Les, you're just like me.
I fucking have to make so
much more money than I make.
I just don't want to, I want to be happy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Not have more money.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm enjoying that
I am making a little more money.
- Good.
- Now because it's taken
12 years to get here--
- That's right.
- Can't I just, I just wanna,
I don't need to make a million dollars.
Like--
- That's right.
- I'm good, we just bought
the house we've always wanted
we, you know, like we're in a good place.
And I do wanna travel more,
so I need more for my travel jar, but--
- What you might be able to do then,
is why don't you put out free
Zooms and free live streams,
which will build up your
personal brand, it's all free.
Which will probably lead to
invites to give some speeches.
I've been able to travel the
world and not pay a dime.
So you might be able to get,
you know, places that, you know,
at first, my offers where,
"We'll pay for your travel."
You know, back in '09
when I started speaking
- Yeah.
- I think that would
be a home-run for you.
If somebody reaches out to
you from Australians, like,
"We'll pay for your travel,
can you come and speak?"
You would like, hang up
and dance all over the building.
- Yeah, yeah, totally would.
- So, I think there's a way
for you to do that as well,
which is to start putting
out more free content,
and when I say content, one of the things
I need to talk about more
is put out more free access.
You know, what I'm doing right now
is the most valuable, right?
The most valuable, I mean, like people,
people buy 50, 60, $80,000 one hour
lunches with me through
charity, things that I do,
you know, like this one on one time,
is something people want.
And I'm doing it right
now for free, you know,
and so you can do that as well.
Create access to your Facebook Lives,
you know, Instagram Lives, Zooms
and then I think that will
lead to demand for you to speak
and that will scratch your travel.
The answer is don't
listen to your husband,
don't listen to your best friend,
don't listen to some of the experts
that you follow on Instagram.
You do not have to start a course
because it's more
scalable, make more money,
you have to follow what
makes you happiest.
And you are clearly in tune with that
and so I'm proud of you.
- Thank you.
Thank you, yeah, I do you love what I do,
and I'm always like,
preaching it to other people.
Like if you hate your job, just like--
- You just have to try, you have to try.
And everybody goes, everyone,
most people are fear based.
So, they're like, "How
am I gonna pay the rent
"and this and that?", and
I keep reminding people,
quit your job in parallel
with quitting your lifestyle.
Actually sell your home and
your car and your fancy handbags
and sneakers and go rent an apartment
and then quit, happiness over everything.
- Yeah, yeah, I agree, yeah.
I think my friends are
sick of me telling them.
- Les, access.
- Yeah.
- Do some screens, you're
gonna stumble on somebody
who's thrown a conference,
who's gonna pay for you to travel.
And, then you'll figure out
if you're good at speaking
in front of groups.
And if you are, you'll
travel the whole world.
- Awesome.
That's awesome, thank you so much, Gary.
- Take care, you're welcome, Les.
- Bye.
- All right, back to Twitter.
If you are not sharing screenshots
of this on your Twitter,
you're making a huge mistake
because you are missing
out on some epic following,
which I think you should not do that.
Crystal, big shout out to
you, I am your 55th follower.
Look at this crew!
I mean, dressed up looking
sharp, Kilby, how are you?
- Doing well, Gary, how are you?
- Good, and what's your name?
- I'm Amanda Sech Brown.
- I'm Kilby Brown.
- [Both] And we are The Property
Hats New York City Team.
- Real estate agents from
New York, Gary, how are you?
- Very nice, I'm really well.
- I'm from Brazil.
- Very nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Really excited, thanks
for having us today.
- Sure.
- So, we live in New Jersey.
We do real estate in Manhattan,
and following you for a few years.
Honestly, I think a few
months ago you told us
to stop following you and just do it.
I think that was you
mentioned for a while.
So I did stop following
you, but I'm back in
and I guess my question is,
we've been doing this about three years.
I left a W-2 paying job you know,
making six figures, I haven't
quite made it where I needed
to be yet on real estate,
now we're shut out,
we can't meet clients,
can't do open houses,
can't call, call can't do anything.
So I need a reset, and
I'm gonna use this time,
amongst many things to do
a reset in my business.
So, what are your ideas as a real estate,
real estate agents, we
are marketing these hats,
we do hats on bass hats in our
videos, that sort of thing.
- Not so local.
- Hats all over Manhattan.
- Love it.
- I'm active on LinkedIn,
I have Instagram,
I've started TikTok, I have
Facebook, all sorts of stuff.
So, what are your thoughts now?
- Let me throw some random things at you.
Number one, have you considered
starting a Facebook group For tri-state?
I would call it the
Tri-state Real Estate Group
where real estate agents,
real estate brokers,
you know, just a community.
One of the biggest things I
believe in is throw the party,
you know, who--
- I have two groups right now.
- Tell me about them.
- But, they're Manhattan groups,
I can change to tri-estate.
- It's less about that, how
active are you in there,
and who are you letting in there?
- One, we just started like two weeks ago,
that was really just potential clients.
The second one we took over
from a guy who's helping us.
That's open to agents, that's
open to everyone I believe.
- I think intent really matters Kilby,
so what I'm trying to do is
get you to be the Pied Piper,
the Gatsby, the person
that throws the party.
And even if people in there
are doing more real estate transactions,
and there may be times
where you look at each other
and said, "Why don't we listen to Gary?"
There's these other real estate agents
that are part of these groups
that are also doing taking
the business from the people
that are in this group,
that have potential clients.
I still believe that in
the macro, being the person
that has the number one
Tri-State Real Estate Group,
as the host or hostess, will
turn out to be ROI beneficial
in a two, three year period.
What that requires is the intent of you
when you have that group is
for you to actually be a host.
Not, you threw them all there
just to sell them a property.
That's a very different mentality
and leads to very different words,
and very different thoughts
coming out of your mouth.
So one of the things that I think mostly,
you know, my sister's a real
estate agent in New Jersey,
so I got closer to it.
One of the biggest mistakes
that I think real estate agents
make is, they don't market,
they don't bring value.
They are salespeople, right?
And so to me, every time since I spoke
at the first In-man connect in like 2010,
my first, I mean, Connect 2010 or 11.
I kept saying, "Be the mayor of your town,
"be the newspaper of your town."
You know, what I would do
if I were you right now
is I would, think about all the businesses
that are struggling in Manhattan as well.
I would probably reach out on
Twitter and Instagram and DM,
and on LinkedIn and DM, restaurant
and other owners in
Manhattan and interview them
how they're getting through the storm.
And then post these
interviews on Facebook.
Because in Manhattan, what
may happen is you may make,
you may interview the one chef who cries
during the interview who's
a famous New York chef.
That's the interview that
gets picked up by ABC News,
it's the interview that gets
a million views on Facebook.
Even with your incredibly
intriguing quirky style,
you'll be memorable, I
think it's about content.
It's about content.
I've been consistent about
this, Kilby, as you know,
but the reality is, it's the
intent behind the content,
I want you to be thinking that you're CNN,
that you're the New York Post,
that you're Bloomberg, you
need to be thinking about
how do I bring value to
this restaurant owner?
And even though, and the
reality is a lot of people
are sitting at home and willing
to do interviews right now,
you'll be able to make some friendships,
but you have to convert
and I believe every
real estate agent will,
she and he will achieve
their best when they convert
into being a news
organization, not a sales man.
I really believe that.
And so I believe like, you know,
I believe that people need to
interview their principals,
their superintendents, the
owners of the businesses
that have been there a long time.
I think this advice works even better
for people in smaller
towns than Manhattan.
- Hmm.
- But I still know it works in Manhattan,
and on the flip side, there's
no small town interview
that's gonna get national coverage,
but, if you get the right
chef or the right barber
with the right thing and
your tiny little audience
on Facebook and you post
them starts with 13 views.
The way Facebook and YouTube work is
you can wake up and it
has a million views.
I think you should quadruple
down on interviews and stories.
I think you know, I've said
it a bunch last couple days
I'm sure maybe you've picked up on this,
I think the two of you
need to tell the story of,
if you made five different
videos on why you quit
a six figure job W-2, like
and when I hear hasn't gotten there yet.
There's a lot of power
in your stories, Kilby,
you can help a lot of people
and you can get people emotionally
attached to your story.
I think you need to go into "story time"
and "newscaster time,"
that's what I would do.
- And it doesn't matter whether
all platforms, you just--
- All platforms.
- Post them everywhere, right?
Like you know, I'm doing
this with "Tea With GaryVee."
The videos are about, you
know, this little clip
will show up on Instagram
will show up on LinkedIn
will show up at Facebook,
will show up on Twitter.
Produce the video and then distribute it
in all different platforms
and the only difference is
you might title it a little different,
you might add some words
that are a little different.
Obviously a LinkedIn crowd
is a little different
than a TikTok crowd, you might write copy
that associates the video
a little bit different,
but distribute everywhere.
You never want to not give yourself
a chance to be discovered.
- Okay, one question I got
besides that outside the hats,
we also like to dance,
so, I also teach Brazilian
dance with dance, swing.
So we also use dance.
- TikTok, TikTok, TikTok, TikTok
is a huge opportunity for you.
- Okay, so just make videos
dancing, make videos--
- If you two made TikTok.
If you two did the trending
dance every day on TikTok,
I guarantee somewhere in the next year,
one of those will go viral,
and that may lead to somebody
who lives in Brooklyn
in Bushwick, clicking on your profile,
seeing that you do real
estate and then emailing you
because you're moving into the city.
That's how it actually works.
That is how it works.
- We'll keep the hats, keep
the dance, keep the energy.
- Keep, of course, keep the hats and dance
'cause you guys like that.
- Exactly.
- What are we doing here, right?
You know, obviously we want
to reach our financial goals
for our stability and
things of that nature,
but at the end of the day,
how you make your money
is more important than how much you make,
and the hats and the dancing
is part of your two souls.
- All right.
- Exactly.
- Beautiful.
- Great job.
- More content, what were
you gonna say, Kilby?
- I was saying great, thank
you very much, great job.
Yesterday also with your
father, really nice.
- Thank you very much.
- I wanted to drink wine in the
middle of the afternoon too.
I waited a little bit,
but it was really great,
really great to see you with your father.
- Kilby, you better sign up
for Wine Text, my dad needs it.
It's a great service if you
buy wine, it's crazy good.
- Okay, I will, I will, thank you.
Thank you Gary, thank you, bye bye.
- Good heat for everybody if
you buy wine on the internet
winetext.com, today we are
selling a $52 pinot noir for 12,
like half price, like
it's just ridiculous.
Great plant trainers, thank you so much.
So we steamer, Blended
Collective CBS, Yogi.
- Gary, thank you so much
for having me on, man.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate it, love your show
and sending me good vibes.
So, thank you so much for that.
- Thank you bro, thank you.
- Little over, oh, you're welcome.
little overview about
me, I started Instagram
back in 2016 to make fun of yoga.
I didn't have a yoga practice,
just to make fun of yoga
and yoga ended up changing my life
and now I have like a yoga brand,
I teach yoga and I post
everywhere like Facebook, TikTok,
you know, just everywhere because of you.
So, I appreciate like
everything you've said
everything you do, my
friend Pedro told me that,
he told me to listen to you.
You literally changed my life.
I got out of $30,000 of debt,
because I sold my house and I moved in
with my in laws for like
four or five months.
So, that like four or
five months was tough,
but it set my whole
future up so much better
with like my side hustle business
and everything like that.
So thank you so much for that.
- So you're, and so Brian, you
literally heard me talk about
that theory, it sat in your
head and you decided to do it?
- I did, yeah, it sat in my head
and I was like really playing
with the fears of like,
making other judgment--
- Judgment.
- I'm 38 years old and like
I just got married, too,
last year, so it's like the judgment--
- I'm so proud, Brian,
I'm so proud of you.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
I appreciate you.
- You know how much courage?
You how much courage it
takes to do that move?
But, I'm so, more proud of you,
because right now, people can
sense your happiness with it,
and so many people have to sell their home
and move in with their in-laws,
and with their friends.
They don't realize it's a huge coup.
It's a huge coup if you
can't afford your lifestyle,
to reset a little
humility, and by the way,
I have no idea how much you
like or don't like your in-laws,
but one of the things
that people don't realize,
and I've gotten some of these emails,
going back in with their
parents or their best friend
or their in-laws, or the one guy went in
with their high school coach.
Also those three, four, five, six months
have been a lot of fun
for a lot of people,
because they got closer
to people that they like.
- Yeah, yeah, and that was a great time
and in-laws are awesome, they had a pool
so it's during the summer
we have to swim a lot,
So yeah, I was like a little vacation--
- How did your in-laws think about it?
Were they practical, and like,
"Hey, Brian, that's really",
like, did they view it as,
did they also see it as
like, "Wow, good on you
"that you had the courage
to do it," did they judge?"
- Yeah, super supportive,
they didn't judge.
They enjoyed us being there,
so we had a good time.
Then it was just time, we
live in our apartment now.
So if--
- Of course.
- I mean, now we're waiting
to possibly buy a house
from this whole thing--
- Of course.
- Yeah, it's such a big
relief off my shoulder
and I was able to focus you know,
more on just my brand and what
I wanna do because I work,
I work at a bank for my day job.
And like, I'm literally like, go, go, go.
Every minute outside my
day job even I'm like,
I'm walking down the hall, whatever,
like I'm on my phone trying
to respond back to people.
And that was my question that I had today
is, you know, I'm making all this content,
I love to make people laugh,
and especially in the yoga community.
That's like my passion, I
love to be an entertainer.
I love to make people
laugh, especially right now
I feel like as a creator,
I have a responsibility
to make people laugh and just kind of
get them out of this rut.
But, especially since I've
been home and I make content,
I try to respond back to everyone's DMs
and just build that community.
How, do you have any advice on managing?
Just being on my phone so much,
Like do you like for example,
do you like, batch your text,
Or do you only go on Instagram
at certain times of the day,
Like, how do you balance?
Because, I feel like I'm at
a almost crossing the line
to cell phone addiction too,
just 'cause I have a wife,
I have a son who's always on there.
- I don't think you have
cell phone addiction,
I think you have
addiction to your passion.
- Yeah, oh, nice.
- You know, the cell phone
just happens to, morning, dad.
- [Dad] I love you, son.
- I love you the most.
Say hello.
- Hello.
- Morning.
- What's up?
I signed up for Wine text
for my wife she loves wine--
- Brian just said he
signed up for wine text.
He's in my, I've got headphones.
- Thank you, thank you, Brian.
- You're welcome.
- Brian, you don't have
addiction to your phone,
you have addiction to
what's on the other side.
The phone is an empty pipe.
And so, and if you're feeling
guilt that you want to spend
a little more time with the fam then
that's on you, that's not the phone.
It's not the phone, it's
what's on the other side
of the phone, people have it so confused.
Everyone's like you're
addicted to your phone.
No you're not, you're
addicted to your friends
that you talk to us, addicted
to phone, no you're not
you're addicted to watching funny videos.
You're always on your
phone, no you're not.
You're addicted to you
know, your business.
So, I think you're addicted
to the right thing,
your passion on the side
hustle, don't demonize yourself
because you're on the
phone 'cause you know what?
That's another judgment for society,
society judges people to sell their home
and go and live with their in-laws.
You have just felt the benefits of that.
Society judges people on their phone,
but they don't realize what's
happening on the other phone.
You're making people
happy on the other side.
- Yes, that's true.
- I'm a proud of you, I
don't look down on you,
I look up at you for that.
- Thank you, I appreciate it.
And thank you for getting
me on TikTok, I love TikTok
and just I love consuming the content
and yeah, it really blows
up pretty fast on there,
you know, my whole brand transformed,
now I'm like doing cussing
yoga videos and like it just--
- Yes.
- Totally transformed,
so I appreciate that.
And--
- Brian, you are on your way.
- I overthought it though,
I overthought TikTok,
I started in July and
I kept deleting videos.
Like I kept them like, this not gonna do,
I kept deleting videos--
- Doesn't matter, not
doing good is, it's time
that everybody realizes
that I get more enjoyment
from my content that doesn't
do well than the reverse,
not doing well is not bad
not doing well is a gift.
It shows you, it gives
you data on something,
it lets you know that
something might not be working
especially after you do
the same thing 50 times.
After one time you can't you
think it's not doing well
and you have to have the
confidence to let somebody
come on your page and see
that you only had 37 views
- Yeah, yes 100%.
- Have you started a Facebook group?
- We have, we actually
do, me and my friend Pedro
who turned me on to you.
- Yep, you told me that.
- We have a podcast,
The Yogi Show Podcast.
We have a Facebook group
there like we're all--
- Okay, good, all right.
- All on Facebook, all everywhere.
I just do, I do what you tell me.
So, I appreciate it and
it took me like a year
for me to like hear someone say that--
- That's right, that's right.
- Like do what Gary does
and you're gonna blow up.
So I appreciate, appreciate you so much,
thank you for having me on here.
- Have a great day.
- Love you, man.
- Proud of you.
Listen, that had--
- Thank you.
- Everybody, that had a
huge piece of content in it,
which is the bottom
line is, I'm telling you
if you don't understand the
step back on selling your home
if you can't afford it,
it is one of the great
moves in our society
and I hope more people do it.
Proud of Brian, did you
just see the happiness
and the confidence in his eyes?
Unbelievable.
Jen, how are you?
- Hi, Gary, nice to see you.
- Nice to see you.
- So, my name is Jennifer Dalton
and I live in East Meadow, New York.
I just want to start
off by saying thank you
for this once in a life opportunity.
I loved your video
yesterday with your dad.
I was laughing, it was
amazing and it reminded me
a lot of my relationship with my father
and how you know, I've been
in the kitchen with him
since I'm four years old,
breaking off bands of string beans
and just building that worth
ethic that is like so valuable.
So, I love your "Tea With GaryVee" show.
This past year, I had a
pretty challenging year.
- I'm sorry.
- Where a lot of the stuff that people
were saying resonated with me,
I mean, I had to move out of my home,
I traded my fancy BMW,
moved back with my parents,
I haven't paid my bills in about a year.
Due to some hardships,
and before quarantine,
I was working three part time jobs.
And, what I learned is that I
love connecting with people.
I love people, I love the
different groups of people.
And, my dream is to open up a coffee shop
where I could build that like, community.
- Community, yeah.
- And have speakers
come in and have events
and have an experienced teach cooking,
you know, like--
- And Jen, Jennifer on
that front, also debate
if you want it to be a coffee shop
because that's a very kind
of like competitive sector
and I see a lot of people who
want to connect with people
and have a hub default into coffee shop.
Just after this call,
play with the idea of
should it be an arcade?
Should it be a hand curated bookstore?
Should it be a juice store?
Should it be tea?
Should it be orange juice?
Maybe it's straight,
maybe it's string bean,
maybe it's a soup store,
like, I love the idea.
Don't just default into coffee shop,
a lot of people are doing that.
Now coffee might be the right one for you,
but, I love the idea for people
that love connecting with
people that are extroverted
and want "a clubhouse" and
build a business around it.
I just want to make sure, I actually think
some people out there like you,
actually have a better idea in them,
but, they don't think
that like for example,
they don't think they can open
a grapefruit store, right?
Where you sell grapefruits,
where you sell grapefruit juice.
But meanwhile, it was their grandma
and their's favorite drink
and with that passion,
they'll stand out more and do even
better selling grapefruit,
grapefruit T-shirts.
Like then they would
have been a coffee shop,
because they don't realize,
yes, there might be 10 times more people
that want coffee than grapefruit,
but there's 12 coffee shops
to divide that demand.
Whereas with grapefruit, there isn't
a single grapefruit store around.
So just also keep in
mind that there might be
something unique for you to do as well.
Just something to keep
in mind, keep going.
- Beautiful.
Yeah, I was thinking like,
especially with everyone
being home, and maybe some jobs
like, getting used to being at home,
people are gonna want a place
to come and do their work
and maybe rent out like
rooms where people could,
you know, do that for some meetings.
- Club houses will always work.
- Yeah, like that third place environment.
- That's right.
- So, like, I also love
what you do, and I love,
I feel like I've been through
quite a bit in my life to
where I could connect with
people on a very deep level.
And I was wondering if you were me,
like, what would you do
to explore that focus,
like energy on that focus?
- Meaning you want to build a community
and talk with people?
- Yeah.
- You know, I would do what I did.
In 2006 I started doing it
with wine, and then 2009
I started doing it with business.
It's literally as simple as making videos
and putting them out on the internet.
Back then that was
Fiddler, YouTube, Facebook
and Twitter, MySpace, right?
Today, it's a slew of things from TikTok
to LinkedIn to other places,
but what's really crazy, Jennifer, is
it's very obvious what
it is, it is content.
It's a podcast, it's a YouTube
show, it's one off videos,
it's starting with six
people that are your friends
and then it builds from there.
It's really as simple as that.
There is nothing too
crazy to the strategy,
the crazy part to the strategy
is the ability to execute.
- So I've been hosting wellness
events like every month
and I rent out a storefront
and then I have like 10
to 12 people come in--
- That's awesome, do you film it?
- No.
- Good.
So next one you do, have a friend film it.
Literally everyone's like but then what?
This literally, then on
the iPhone if they have to,
you should absolutely film
it because that's content.
Maybe you getting
somebody to try something,
or you saying something
to somebody that's there,
is the video that starts your career.
- Beautiful.
Thank you so much for everything.
- You're welcome.
- Appreciate it.
- Thanks Jennifer, have a great day.
- Have a great day.
- My friends, everybody, just
like with Jennifer right now,
it is documented, like do not do anything
that's public without it being filmed.
And then, chop it up and post produce it
and put it out in the world.
Simple as that, simple as that.
- I'm good, I'm good, thanks me the live.
Thank you very much, it's an honor.
- You're welcome, where are you from?
- I am from Greece.
- Very nice, nice to see you.
- Thank you very much.
I have two question for you,
so, I will give you a bit
of context for both of them.
The first one is I'm in
the university right now.
I'm studying computer engineering.
And I had a really rough
start with my university,
but after personal
journey, I found my base
and I have a plan and
I executed to graduate.
My question is this, I am
26 years old right now,
and I have, I really feel I
stand behind in that department,
and, I could do a like some
advice on how to boost my resume
and convince others that
I have a lot to offer.
And I am very passionate
about learning and work.
- I think the answer is less
about boosting your resume.
And it's more about asking more people.
So, I see a lot of
people who feel insecure
about their resumes,
whether they're behind,
they didn't go to the best
school and I always laugh
because I always say to
them, you don't understand.
It's not about having the best resume,
it's about asking the
most people for a job.
So to me, you have more
than a good enough resume
for one to 500 businesses in
the world right now, right now.
It's just that you have
to submit your resume
and you have to reach
out to them and apply.
So, so many people are
in their head, worrying
and dwelling that they're behind.
Instead, they should be on
LinkedIn and reaching out
to CEOs and CMOS, and CIOs
and CTOs in your situation
and sending in the resume and saying
"I have the most passion,
read this resume."
All you need is one person to say yes.
- So it's about quantity with a good...
Yes, okay.
- Hold on one second,
I'm gonna finish that
'cause a lot of people watching
'cause you, I can see that you got it.
It is quantity with upfront
context in the first two
or three sentences to
get them to get excited
and then you're on your way.
- Context in the not resume,
like a motivation letter
something like that.
- It's if you know you're sending it to,
it's if you know you're
sending your resume
to a video game maker, you
make a reference to loving,
you know, Zelda when you were a kid.
You know, just something
to give it a little boost.
- I see, I see.
- If you, if you're applying
to a company in Poland,
you make a reference in the opening email
about somebody that you
grew up with in Greece
who was from Poland, if that's true.
You know, you give a little,
a little flavor to it.
- I see, Pperfect, thank you very much.
My second question is this,
I have this entrepreneurship
issue with my twin brother.
And yes, and we are trying
to start some side hustling
beside our main jobs
because it's not enough.
Our goal is to have a financial freedom.
And it's, I feel like it's in Europe,
it's very different than in America.
For example, my brother
has started writing,
and he's really trying
to go that way and great,
have clients and create
a career out of it.
And I was thinking about flipping
and side hustles doing in Europe.
But, I understand it's very
difficult from America,
it's not so easy.
- That's right, it's not as easy.
The websites aren't the
same, it's different.
- And there are regulations
that are different,
and I was asking if you have any advice
on either going for flipping
and this just what to study about it
because I'm ready to do it
or some other European related stuff.
- Flipping is definitely harder in Europe
than it is in the US
because the websites, the culture,
there's a lot of differences.
I do see some people in Europe
doing very well in flipping
by starting an Instagram account
and posting their items on Instagram.
And then people reply,
and then they meet up
and they change it so, or they ship it.
So I've seen some
Europeans get some traction
on flipping by posting
the items on Instagram.
And like, literally starting
an account that says,
"Selling from Greece",
and just taking a photo
and saying "$80 for this
hat" and "$4 for this mug",
and so I've seen some success like that.
But, let's go back to
the most important part,
it's very important to me,
and we talked about a two
callers ago with Brian.
When I heard you say financial freedom,
Pentelas, just remember one thing,
financial freedom comes in a lot of forms.
It comes in how much you make,
but more importantly it
comes in how much you spend.
- Of course, lifestyle is always relative
with the money you make.
- It is and I think this
generation, everybody 15 to 35
needs a good, good, good reminder
that you don't have to buy
the most expensive home
you can afford, the most
expensive car you can afford.
Like, we need to live
a little more humbly,
because it's gonna lead to
a lot more breathing room
to live with financial freedom.
- Yes, I don't really think
I have this kind of
problem if you said it.
I really feel the
freedom, I'm talking about
is about doing stuff
and having experiences
that money won't be the problem.
- I love that, I respect that.
- So--
- So listen, I think the
flipping can be done on Instagram
and I think that there's
a lot of other things
you can consider, I think
when you have the ability
to be a developer like you are,
you might be able to develop
some stuff on the side
that you know, that people
pay $5 a piece for a download.
Like, there's a lot of clever stuff.
Developers can do a little
hack that helps people
make their content better
that they pay $2 a month
for subscription, low cost
subscription technology,
I think is a very interesting business.
Maybe you start something
that is like a software
that helps people make
better TikTok videos
and it costs $3 a month.
All of a sudden, that can
be an interesting business,
I would say maybe a side hustle that leans
into your natural strength of development.
- So, this goes more for
a macro kind of stuff
because, you have to gain the experience
and create more quantity?
- That's right.
- Okay, thank you very
much, it was an honor.
- Thank you my friend.
- Thank you very much.
- All right, Gus, let's keep this going.
Ryan, what's good?
- Hey, hey, Gary, thank
you so much for having me.
- I'm happy to have you, bro.
Where are you from?
- I'm from Chicago.
I actually had a quick tip for Pentelas
because, I'm a software engineer
- Please.
- So if the company
that you're applying for
has a public product or API,
take a small part of that
product and build it.
And bring it to the interview.
- Agreed.
- I've used that couple
times and it's really good.
- You know, making and doing over talking
always works and that's what
you're talking about, Ryan.
So I appreciate that.
- So my question is, so last week,
I had the idea of selling
printed images on toilet paper,
and I contacted a guy who is willing
to drop-ship them for me
and I started a Shopify store,
Facebook, Instagram page,
and that's as far as I've gotten.
I've sold two toilet papers,
one to my mom and one
to my best friend, so--
- Good start, good start.
- I'm curious if you have
any advice for what can I do?
I was thinking that Facebook
ads or Instagram ads
might be a way to try and kick it off,
but do you have any advice
for what I can do to get out there?
- I really like Instagram story
ads, they're under priced.
They have functionality when you're like,
I mean, literally, here's what I would do,
I'll just do the whole thing for you,
"What's up Instagram?
"It's Ryan, I'm about to
tell you something crazy.
"I've started a toilet paper
that we've printed things on.
"If you want to swipe up to
find out more, I know it's crazy
"and I know right now, toilet paper
"is kind of like a thing in our culture,
"but I'm telling you,
check it out, swipe up."
Now, that ad on Instagram Stories
is gonna cost you so little,
and if you target 25 to 29 year
olds, you can also do like,
"What's up Chicago?
"It's Ryan, I live here
too, I'm an entrepreneur.
"I had an idea last week, this
toilet paper has print on it.
"I know it's crazy", you know,
"I know there's a
shortage of toilet paper,
"there's really not,
so don't be mad at me.
"Swipe up if you want to check it out."
That ad, why that ad's interesting is
now you targeted on the
back end of Chicago.
You are from Chicago, you
created a connection point.
Notice how I went right to it
in the first three seconds.
Every Instagram story ad,
You have to win in the first
three seconds or you're dead.
You know how fast we go through
Instagram stories, right?
So you holding up the visual of the,
so you're gonna need a roll sent to you
because, obviously you have
somebody drop-shipping,
you holding that up and quickly saying,
"What's up guys, I'm Ryan from Chicago,"
like literally, or I
probably go this route,
"Chicago stand up, it's me, Ryan."
You know, like, you're
really trying to stop people.
Because, the Instagram story
ads are super under-priced,
the swipe up functionality
sends to your Shopify, right?
And you could be so targeted with it.
And then what you'll
learn if Chicago works
is you're going to start,
where did you go to college?
- For two years, before dropout.
- Where?
- DePaul university.
- Even better.
So you can target by
DePaul, you can be like,
DePaul, I went to DePaul,
you start really going segmented.
You can start and then
you could, by the way,
you don't have to be from
Chicago to say, "Hey, Chicago",
you can literally be like New
York, what's good, you know?
So I think Instagram story
ads, swipe up to your Shopify
are going and I want you to be in it.
And like literally just
do that ad, it will work.
- Awesome, I'll do it.
- To me that is the number
one conversion Shopify tactic
sitting there, if you hit the creative,
I always want people no
matter how extroverted
or introverted they are to star in the ad,
'cause people stop when they see people.
- Hmm.
- You're just gonna make people laugh.
Like, I don't know, what
if we can target by humor
or humor interests, I don't
know if that's still in play,
but like, it's just
like, there's definitely,
I definitely feel like a
psychological graph of like,
people that find things
funny would probably resonate
with the print, you know, like,
I mean, there's something clearly there.
- So, the first one I did was
a Donald Trump toilet paper--
- So I would target Democrats,
because you wouldn't do
as well with Republicans.
And that's how we do it.
- Yeah, right?
- And then you know,
then you do the Biden one
for the other side, and then you do read,
like, there's just like,
there's a lot to do there.
So I think that there's a lot of,
you'll clearly get a lot
of reaction if you run
that piece of creative in
New York and California,
where people skew more
liberal than conservative.
Like that's gonna, if you
can target by California
and New York, target by humor interests.
You're gonna get some,
I'm telling you right now,
now that I hear how
"polarizing", the content is,
I would definitely do
Instagram story swipe ups,
eight, like today, today.
- Okay, I have another one that is like
COVID-19 health tips.
So you can gift someone
a toilet paper roll
with tips on how to keep themselves safe.
- I think you understand the creative
that will get people to react and buy.
I think to your point you
need the marketing strategy
to build awareness, I'm
getting more confident
on the Instagram swipe up
ads as you add context.
- Do I need content on the actual pages,
the Facebook, Instagram,
do I need to be posting
that consistently, too?
- Yes, 'cause you've got, I mean, look,
you should probably post that
Donald Trump and COVID post
in your feed and tag a
bunch of celebrities.
Inevitably somebody is
going to respond to that,
you know, like, "I would probably",
you know, I don't know
how many, I don't know
what the max tagging is on
Instagram, trying to remember
if it's 10 or 20 people or 30, whatever.
But, I probably post the
same post over and over
just tagging 10 liberal
celebrities, which the majority are,
like literally two, I probably
post the same exact post
three times a day with 10
to 20 more people tagged.
All you know this, all
you need is one of them,
to like repost it and you're
off to the fucking races.
- Sweet.
- Thanks for for your advice.
- Wish you well, talk to you soon, thanks.
All right, going back to Twitter,
first hour getting on the boards here.
Gus, give me one second, just
want to talk for a second.
First hour getting here in the boards,
a lot of good advice as well this morning.
Really enjoying my mornings with you guys.
You know, I'm probably gonna be sad
when I have to go back to my real life.
And can't do "Tea With GaryVee" anymore,
but I'm really enjoying it,
I'm really enjoying the moments with you.
I really appreciate everybody
who's sharing on Twitter.
And I'm just grateful and I
hope the advice is helping.
I really want to go back
to Brian one more time.
I hope you saw the joy in that man's face,
he had the courage to
move in with his in-laws,
a lot of you can move in
with your grandparents,
your uncle, your mom,
your dad, a best friend,
if they're willing to.
If we just had more humility in the world,
and people were willing
to take a step back
to go two steps forward, he had
a home, he just got married,
but he was 30,000 in debt
and by selling the home
and moving in with his in-laws
for four to six months,
and then moving into apartment, his world
is so much happier, and who gives a shit
if everybody makes fun of
you that you sold your house
and thinks you're a loser.
Fuck them, like their life has nothing
to do with yours and vice versa.
So that was just a real powerful one,
I've been talking a
lot about that concept,
trading in your car, like just that stuff.
I'm very passionate
about that and that's it.
So, anyway, going back to some
of these T-posts real quick,
and I'll be ready in a
second, Dustin, Andrew.
Humphrey, thank you for sharing.
Matt Wilmer, thank you for sharing that,
I'ma actually going to give you a follow.
Matt, I'm your 1630th follower.
All right, Dustin, I'm ready.
Christian, how are you?
- I'm doing great, how are you?
- I'm very well, where are you from?
- I'm from Kingston, Jamaica,
this is awesome to be talking to you.
- It's awesome to be
talking to you, my friend.
What a beautiful country.
- Yes, it is and we are under
the same quarantine lockdown
as most places in the world.
So--
- Are there a lot of cases in Jamaica?
- We're up to 36 this morning,
so our government's done
a really good job so far
of doing containment and quarantine.
- Very nice.
- So, I have two questions,
one kind of general,
one more specific, but let
me give a little context.
I work for a startup insurance company
here in Kingston called Iron Rock.
And we launched four years ago
listed on the local Stock
Exchange to raise capital.
Have a very small team, only 14 people.
In comparison, the next largest guy
has 80 odd, 90 odd employees.
So we're really, really small
and we use technology to scale.
We've gone from Greenfield,
zero dollars of revenue
on day one to just about 5
million US dollars a year,
in gross revenue, so we're not
doing bad after four years.
My role here is--
- What's the net revenue on
that number, do you know?
- Yeah, the net revenue is
about, I can do it in J dollars,
I haven't converted it to US dollars.
- No worries.
- So my role here is
I'm the General Manager
in charge of production
sales, including marketing.
And my kind of objective
is to make Iron Rock
the cool tech insurance company.
We're small, typically
everybody hates insurance,
insurance is not a real sexy field.
It's kind of stodgy stuff very old school.
And so, we want to create
content that positions us
as different, as young, as hip,
as the cool tech insurance company.
Because we're so small,
we outsource all of our
social creation to a to
another small company,
it's not done in house, because
the team is really small.
We're on Facebook, and IG,
and I just finished reading
your book, by the way,
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right
Hook, and it was awesome.
Thank you very much.
But, what it showed me was
that the bulk of our content
has been right hooks on Iron Rock's page.
And so, I'm kind of making a switch now
to go and focus more on
jabs, and I am the persona.
I'm the voice of the
company in the social space.
And so I've created my own personal page,
Christian Watt JA and I'm
struggling with what to post.
So I want to explain
our thing at Iron Rock
is to simplify insurance,
it's a technical thing,
people don't like it, people
think we always rip you off.
So my goal is, I want to
simplify, explain the coverage,
explain how it really works.
And when I've done a few of those videos
on Iron Rock's page, the
engagement is 10, 15, 20 times
higher than any of the Right
Hook posts or anything, yeah.
- Anything valuable, people like,
anything that's asking
them for their money,
people don't like, it's not complicated.
- Exactly, so, but, I'm trying to,
should I post them, so one quick question,
should I post them as Iron Rock JA page,
or as me, the general manager?
- Both.
- Both?
- So post as me and then
put it to the page as well?
So trying to create it, it's a bit stuffy,
it's a bit boring sometimes,
what kind of angle,
is my first general question,
would be good to create engagement?
- It's about creativity, so for example,
I would probably go to
a jerk chicken stand
and literally film it from there,
and maybe even ask the
person that's serving you,
"Hey," like while you're doing your video,
you're like, "Oh, by the
way, you have insurance?"
And of course, something
funny is gonna happen,
they're gonna say, "I don't fucking."
You know, it just making
it more interesting, right?
So--
- So don't do them
sitting from my desk in my own house.
- Correct, do not.
- Okay.
- You know, I think
when people, think about
how Facebook and Instagram
work, if already behind you
is a sunny jerk chicken
stand, that's already
more interesting, that's already
more culturally relevant.
Think about the other 500
things that matter to Jamaicans
whether, you know, whether
it's landmarks or silly?
So, I think setting, a
lot of times setting,
the setting is very powerful.
- Okay, okay, and my second question
was something more specific.
So I had an idea for
a particular, I guess,
theme or hashtag that I wanted to create
because, everybody has
this stigma for insurance,
I wanted to create a conversation around
#EveryoneHatesInsurance.
But I'm kind of nervous--
- I like it.
- You do?
Because, I don't know if
we should be associated
with a hashtag like that.
- Of course you should.
- Yeah?
Because, when you dig into it,
you're being empathetic to the consumer.
- Okay, right.
- You're aligning yourself
with the customer, got it?
- I try and get feedback from them
as to why they hate, what's
their issues, what problems?
- You're with them instead of being upset
at them for hating insurance.
- Got you, got you, got you.
Those are my two questions, Gary.
I've been following for about two years--
- Christian, one other thing, last thing,
if you look at insurance success
in Asia, in America, in
Europe, a lot of the things
that work are irrelevant, right?
Irreverence excuse me, irreverence.
So Geico, or you know, or progressive like
the creative is around something
that has nothing to do
with insurance, so--
- Right.
- I think humor, something
a little bit different,
If you go make a video of you just being
in your "stodgy suit", running in like
literally filming while you
run in between a soccer,
a football match on the
beach with some kids
or some people and just get the reactions.
There's something there.
- Okay.
- You see where I'm going?
- Yeah, yeah, try and use humor
and trying to stay away
from direct insurance.
- And something that has,
like doesn't make any sense.
It's just a man in a suit
running across a beach
where people and they're mad at you
and it just, try shit, try shit.
- Yeah, okay.
- All right.
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Yep.
- Let's keep this going.
Jamaica, Greece, we've gone
really international tonight.
Hello?
- Hello.
- What's your name?
- I'm Deanna, it's to meet you.
- Yeah, that's so nice to meet you too.
- A little bit--
- What's your question?
- A little bit about me first,
I am a university student in Virginia.
I study biomedical science
and I'm a Spanish minor.
My passion is in the medical
field as well as with Spanish.
So I'd like to make use of that.
I recently got an internship
in Colombia, the country
and you know, it's expensive to do it,
but that leads to my first question,
how would you like, if
you were in my position,
how would you fund that trip?
And I have a little bit of time to do it.
- My favorite thing to push people towards
is to sell something, you know?
I just I think it's been remarkable for me
over the last few years to see people
that have gotten into "flip culture".
You know, like when I see this stuff even
over your shoulder right now,
like those cups up there,
and mugs and that, you know,
tchotchkes I'm always like,
"Do you still care about
them, are they yours?"
So, you may know like, I
always think in terms of like,
you know, if one has the ability to sell,
to buy something and sell
it, starting with the stuff
laying around their house
that they don't like anymore,
and then going to Goodwill,
garage sales, you know,
thrift stores, buying bulk on
eBay and selling it on Amazon.
Deanna, nothing, nothing
accelerates creation
of like revenue better
than somebody not realizing
they were good at flipping
and selling stuff,
and then them trying it
and being good at it.
I mean, I see people who
started at zero, six months ago,
take screenshots of their eBay account,
showing me four, five,
seven, nine, 10, $12,000,
'cause they got good at it.
So I don't know if that's in you,
some people are really bad at it
and really don't like the process of it,
but, that would be number one.
Number two, would be to, you know,
really just add more on my back
so just good old fashioned,
grinding more, another job
while I am in university,
that's just real talk, you know, like
when you're in that position, you know,
number three, just to go
through all the variables.
I would speak to every relative
and play a borrow game,
like straight up, I think
too many kids ask for money
instead of borrowing money.
So going to like your
great uncle and being like,
"Yo, I will pay you back in
two years, the 500 bucks,
"it would mean the world to
me, I'm in a tough spot."
I don't think there's anything wrong
with borrowing money from relatives.
You know, I wouldn't put I
wouldn't put a stigma around that
if you're feeling that stress.
But, you know, but really besides
doing something that
you can do for yourself
to make money entrepreneurially
like the flipping,
getting a job, just
another job and saving.
A grind job, late night
job or borrowing money,
those are the three packs in
this scenario in my opinion.
- Okay.
- Have you ever sold anything
on eBay or Craigslist
or Facebook marketplace or Mercari?
- I don't have much to sell.
- Understood, how, do you have 20 bucks?
- Yeah, yeah, I just got paid today,
so I have a little bit more than 20 bucks.
- You know, to me, there's a great story.
I got an email where somebody
was in a very similar spot
when I started talking about flip life.
And they'd literally started
with 20 bucks, literally,
you know, you're in a
little bit of a tough spot
because, we're in quarantine right now
but what they did was
they went to Goodwill,
they went to some thrift
stores, they bought like,
I'm trying to remember the
story, seven to 10 items.
They sold that on eBay and Craigslist
and Facebook marketplace they
got, they made 100 on that.
They went back, it's just that process,
you know, that I'm very passionate about.
The less entrepreneurial version
is just another fucking job
or number three, just borrowing money.
There is not, not that many options.
They fall in the bucket
of making it for yourself,
you know, by the way,
another way to make money
is labor not buying and selling.
So, maybe it is, you know, cutting hair,
maybe it is mowing lawns, maybe it is like
the reality is it's just
grind life, you know?
- Okay.
- And then number four is
taking a step back and saying,
"Fuck, even though this
opportunity for this internship
"in Colombia is so remarkable,
I am not in a place right now
"where I can actually afford it.
"So, let me go next year
"to whether it's Colombia, Peru or
"somewhere else that maybe I feel like
"this is just not the right timing
"even though fuck, I really want to."
That's okay, because you're a young woman
and sometimes, you know,
disappointment like that
is the ignite to some of
the other three things
that I told you are options.
- Okay.
- I wish you well.
- I have, thank you.
I have two other questions
as well, if that's okay?
- Okay, let's go quick.
- Okay, I want to start a nonprofit
once I become established
as a doctor, and hopefully
in one of the so called third
world countries, thank you.
And I was wondering if you had any advice
as to how to start that?
- There is, send me an
email when this is done
to gary@VaynerMedia, I'm
gonna send you two books.
I'm on the board of
one, Pencils of Promise
and I'm a well member to Charity Water.
Both of the founders, Adam
and Scott have written books
that are just remarkable on how
they started from zero, zero
as kids and started
these massive nonprofits.
I think you should read them,
I'm gonna send you both books.
- Thank you.
- So email me to gary@VaynerMedia
and put your address in there
and I'm gonna send you both books.
- Okay.
And then my last question is for my dad,
he wants to be a kind of an
entrepreneur business owner,
and I was wondering what
advice would you have
for him to start off, he's
almost 50 and you know--
- He's young.
- Yeah.
- He's young, you know what,
I think the right answer here is
I'm going to add five more books,
all five business books that I've written.
And I'm going to send it to him, tell him
to start watching my content
and other people's content.
He needs to get educated
on the modern moments
about entrepreneurship, and
then decide to start a business
around something he loves.
That will work most,
that is the highest likelihood to success.
- Okay.
- All right?
- Thanks, Deanna.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- Gary@VaynerMedia, put
your address in there.
- Got you.
- Okay?
Bye.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
"Tea With GaryVee" brought
to you by this white mug.
By the way, that's been
funny been getting reached
by a lot of tea companies,
a lot of mug companies
for sponsorship, it's crazy.
Ronnie.
- Yo, what's up, Gary?
- Live is good, bro, how are you?
- I'm doing great, man, I can't believe
I'm here talking to you,
you are like next to my mom,
my ultimate hero, man, thank you so much.
- Thank you, where are you at?
- Super grateful, I'm in a town
called New Braunfels, Texas,
right between San Antonio and Austin.
- Understood.
- So, man, my question
really, I feel kind of like
a couple of other people
you've talked to you like,
I'm so happy where I'm at in my life.
I'm a videographer, photographer,
social media practitioner
here in my town, about 80,000 people.
You know, and I make content
for small businesses,
help them promote
themselves on the internet.
And that's what I love
doing the content creation
is just, that's my passion.
But, you know, for the past three years,
I was able to also take
some of your advice
and create kind of like a
hyper-local news source on
primarily Facebook and Instagram.
It's gotten a lot of attention
with the local community,
I mean, they look to it
or, you know, breaking news
a lot of time it's business
and entertainment oriented,
It's not so much hard news.
But, you know, I find myself
in a place where I've got
this really loyal audience
that's super engaged,
ton of attention, and I have some friends
and people that are
colleagues in the same space,
they're always kind of
encouraging me to figure out
more ways to monetize
that side of my business.
You know, the way I look at it is
I've got the content creation side
and the distribution side.
And, you know, my passion is
with the content creation,
I'm not necessarily, I don't
feel like I'm a businessman,
I don't feel like I'm an entrepreneur.
But I've built this platform out
and it kind of just provides a
ton of value to the community
and never brings--
- And brings awareness to you
that may lead to business
on the other side.
- 100, absolutely.
- You are monetizing it.
- I am, yeah.
- Your friends are looking
at it one dimensional.
- For sure.
I guess the only thing,
the only reason I hesitate
and they catch my attention
when they say that
is because, like you always say, man,
I feel like I've already won.
I'm doing you know what I love to do,
but, that being said,
I would love to turn
this into a real business
instead of just a one man show, and grow--
- Have you considered
bringing in the young hustler
Sara or Rick, who really have
hunger, who loved the news
or distribution side of things,
who you might be able to give five to 49%
depending on how great you feel
about them to really drive that side?
- I teamed up with a good friend of mine
and we tried to do that
50-50 for a little while.
It didn't work out, but you know,
I think just talking to you
and saying it out loud--
- Yes, yeah, just saying it out loud
just 'cause one thing didn't work out
doesn't mean the next one can't.
The other thing you can do is say,
"Hey, listen," let's just role play,
I'm Javier and you're trying to,
actually you be Javier,
I'll be you and I'd be like,
"Listen Javier, I've really
enjoyed our two meetings.
"I think you might be the guy,
"I love that you interned
at CNN that year,
"I love that you've
worked on local websites,
"I had a really tough
experience" or not even tough.
"I had an experience that didn't work out,
"When the forum friend, I'm
scared to give up equity
"for this baby 'cause this is my baby.
"But, I'm going to do what
other startups do with you.
"Like, if you're willing
to take the risk, Javier,
"I hope you can tell that I'm a good guy.
"Here is what I'd like to
do, I'd like to pay you
"a little bit in year one for it,
"but after six months, if it's working,
"then you can kick into getting 10% of it.
"But, if it doesn't work after six months,
"you're gonna have to trust me.
"I'm not a bad guy, I'm just
trying to protect myself
"because right now I would say no,
"because I'm scared to give you 10%
"and then it to not work
out and then I regret it.
"So, just like it's
called a cliff, Javier,
"in other startups where you
work until you hit one year,
"you don't get any equity,
I'd like to cliff you
"for the first six months.
"If you go great, then you go.
"Your vulnerability is
me trying to screw you
"or deciding that you weren't good enough,
"but that is what I'm offering
"and I do have 20 other
people that are interested,
"but I think you're my guy."
I think that's the combo running.
- Yeah, got it, man.
All right, Gary, again,
man, honestly more important
than any question I can ask
you, I just want to say thanks
for everything that you
do for our community, man,
you're the best.
- Ronnie, I think that you
should, thank you, brother.
Ronnie, I think you should reach
out to every local business
and do an interview right now with them
on Zoom, on Instagram, record it like,
right now with all this downtime,
if I'm hearing you straight,
one on one interviews,
five minutes on how they're
getting through this,
how they are, give them
one minute at the end,
a speed round to promote their business,
I would fucking make 25 of
those a day if I were you.
I would literally DM--
- I put it out on my
channel to the community?
- I would go ham him right now.
I would go 24 hours breaking
news, a.k.a your version
20 business interviews a fucking day.
You don't need to edit
them, you just record them
and post them with a little copy.
You do four minutes on
how you're handling it
what's your you know, what
are you thinking about?
You know, I've almost
I do in five minutes,
two minutes on their
background in the community,
two minutes on how they're handling it
and one minute to promote their business.
It would be such a public service.
- Yeah, I did that last week,
like two or three times,
people loved it, and then I just stopped.
I mean, it just, it was a lot of one.
The whole COVID-19 thing
covering some of this stuff,
it just kind of drained because
it was kind of just super,
you know, heavy for what
I'm used to producing.
- I think you can go the other way.
Let's go with optimism on it,
You know, this is an optimist
to make it optimistic,
like lean it towards optimism.
- For sure.
- Awesome, brother.
- Love you, man
- Talk to you.
- Love you more.
- Thanks Gary.
- Bye bye.
Thanks, Rod.
All right, let's keep
going back to Twitter.
If you're watching right
now, time does fly,
time flies when you're
listening, it's true.
Like this is going super fast and fun.
Hi, hi, Vicki, good to see
you, give me one second.
Just try, Chris Bolam, I'm
gonna follow you, my friend.
You've been around for a while.
Thank you, great to see you.
- How you doing?
- I'm well, I'm sure you're challenged
with this COVID 'cause an ice
cream store is not necessarily
in the best position during this time.
- No, plus, obviously we're in a tourism,
what would normally be
hotspot with spring break
and obviously clear water hit the news
'cause it was doing the wrong thing.
So, kind of all the mom and
pop shops absolutely challenged
to do the right thing and keep it safe.
We closed for a few days,
which was absolutely dire
because spring breaks when obviously,
we were hoping to put
money back in the pot
because we just spent all of
our savings on the new store.
So, that obviously is going to
take a long time to recover.
But--
- Yes.
- Moving forward, my
concern is now obviously
with the people that were gonna come down
this year for tourism are not gonna come.
So, when it does finally
get back to a little bit
of normality for tourism,
we're still gonna be
at the back end of the queue to survive.
And so, we've done curbside
for the last three days,
which I wasn't sure
initially it would work
'cause I needed to work out
a way they could be safe
when we did minimum four
pint ice cream deal.
Pre pay by invoice, when you arrive,
call us, it gets brought out.
So, we kind, all the
friction, that was amazing,
because we've just managed
to bring in some money,
but obviously that's a short term stop
to getting anywhere near close
to what we should be doing.
- You know, unfortunately, and
I've been thinking about you
because I saw you on social a little bit
and you know, it's also on my mind,
I was like, kind of like
racking my brain unfortunately.
You know, it's the same thing with all
my restaurant friends in New York.
There's only so much you can do.
You know, we've lost some
clients on the Vayner side
that are selling clothes, right?
And just the retail clothes
and even the online clothes
players are not doing
well, because that's just
not what people are
thinking about right now.
And so, you know, unfortunately,
also having a seasonal
business where it's not like,
you know, you open and we're just back
to our building back
up to our normal main,
and it's just all the
same, the reality is,
is no different than a hurricane,
no different than a
war, no different than,
you know, an earthquake, you
know, that takes down a highway
and then hurts all those
businesses in New York,
no different than when they decide
to put up a subway station,
and they close one side of the street
and you're on that side of the street.
This is what's so scary and
real about entrepreneurship.
Sometimes, there is no answer
and that doesn't mean give up,
what it means is you can
only do what you can do.
And I think one of the reasons, Vicki,
and I know you watch a lot of the content,
the story time thing, is the thing
that I'm most focused on right now,
'cause it's the one thing
that everybody can control,
the trials and like, just,
you know, the reality
is putting out content about the stories
or about the product or how
he came up with the recipes
is really at some level,
besides the promotion
of curbside for you, are
really the two options
that you have to actually attack.
Other than that, we're
at the mercy of like,
the reality of the situation.
- Yeah, I think as well
the hardest thing for me
is having obviously come
from the UK to the US
and obviously every single bit of savings
and we saved for three years.
We had a nice pot of
money which was just saved
'cause I knew we would
have to move locations.
So, then to have that pot of money
and put 90k in to the new store
and then be looking at my bank account
and going, "Shit I've
got staff to think about
"and the backstop that
I've had for 16 years
"of retail in London and US."
For the first time in my life
at the worst possible point,
I don't have that kind of fallback.
I mean, I've got amazing
staff, all the young kids
live at home, and they're all right,
don't worry about us, which is great.
I've got one full time member
of staff, which obviously,
her and I are kind of clinging to call
what we can to kind of keep it going.
But of course, like everybody
else being an immigrant,
our visa is due for renewal this year.
So, we also have to, at some
point, go back to London,
and obviously show the
embassy that we're worthy
to be able to stay in the
US for another five years.
So, it's a challenge for immigrants.
- The good news there, is
my intuition on the re-up
on the five years that the COVID scenario
is probably gonna help you,
I think a lot of people
are gonna get passes based on that.
So, I would argue that that
will probably work out.
I would also argue that
this is a real challenge,
and I think you know, much like we talked
when you were in New York at the 40s.
I still think an ice
pack direct to consumer,
not just relying on your local area
is something that you're
going to have to consider.
Shipping ice cream in
pints around the country
is something you have to consider.
It's just something you have to consider.
I would spend a lot of time
right now on the packaging.
You know what I probably do if I were you?
I'd probably, and you might
have done this already,
so this is more general
information for people.
I probably order five to
seven pints of ice cream
from people who do ship around the country
just to see how they ship it.
You know, what did they, you know,
we're launching a food
version of Wine Text
called Yummy Text, we
actually already have,
and, we're doing a lot of that right now
because we have a lot of soft cheese,
we don't want it to melt you
know, that kind of stuff.
But, I really think, Vicki,
and you've become my friend
through this process, I rarely do this,
but I would absolutely
give awareness to you,
would really promote it, if you like,
I really think you have
to have a meaningful
direct to consumer national
shipping ice cream model,
and you have to make sure it doesn't melt
from Clearwater to San Jose.
- I think that's the biggest challenge
because obviously you're
reliant on the carriers.
And you're also reliant on the airlines,
and we did look at it before
and there's a kind of whole host of
you have to get nutritional
content on it on each thing,
and obviously, all the
allergies and stuff.
And that's what I kind of fell down
because nutritional content
is like it's expensive,
because it all has to get
sent away to kind of work out.
So I mean--
- I just don't think, I
don't know all those details,
but, I can tell you right now, some things
are required for long term success.
I couldn't be more passionate
of you figuring out
how to ship ice cream.
- Yeah.
- I just couldn't, I couldn't period.
And maybe you know, when
I hear what you're saying,
I'm like, "Man, I hope it
didn't make it more complicated
"than it actually is"
like, I would just really,
I would really recommend ordering five,
from five different places
that do ship ice cream
to your home right now
and like reverse engineer
how they did it.
- Yeah, yeah, well I
appreciate for your help and--
- Thanks Vicky, I wish you well.
- All right.
- Good luck.
- Take care everyone.
- Vicky, direct to consumer
ice cream, I will help you.
I will put out two to
three pieces of content,
which, there you go,
you just saved $80,000
in marketing promotion,
I will do that for you
because I want to, but I really
want you to take it serious.
- You need to get some
of that coffee ice cream.
- You know how much I love it.
Talk to you soon.
- Love you, bye.
You know, some circumstances
are just more challenging
than others, you know, Vicki's
ice, the last two, right?
Dee doesn't have anything
to sell in her house.
You know, I'm like, "Hey,
sell stuff in your house",
and she's like, I don't got shit, right?
And, ice cream in a town in
Florida like that seasonal,
that doesn't you know, there's
some real tough situations
out there, but we're gonna fight
and look for angles
and keep chipping away.
Let's keep going on "Tea with GaryVee."
- Hey, what's up, Gary?
- How are you, brother?
- Good, good, I appreciate
you having me on today.
- Happy to do it.
- I just wanna say thank
you 'cause back in 2018
when you had your crush a book signing,
I was one of the people that came out
and you ended up signing this for me,
and I remember you stuck around like,
you were trying to get out for your family
and, you ended up like literally staying
like an hour over just
to like get everybody
through your side, that means the world.
- Thank you for seeing that.
- You're welcome.
Yeah, so I guess I just had
a couple questions for you.
So, I do fashion photography--
- Love it.
- In New York and basically...
Yes, I've decided to go
like niche, you know,
'cause I've, over the years kind of like,
perfected what my craft is,
and I've decided to go
into fashion and I guess,
do you have any advice, like
for me like going forward,
like is there anything
I could do differently?
Like--
- What do you want to happen,
to build brand awareness
around yourself so that people book you?
- Pretty much, yeah, more brand stuff,
for all like different brands.
- You know, I think a
signature, when I hear that,
I think a signature play like
a podcast or YouTube show,
I'm a very big believer
in a signature product,
and then you build from
all the concept of that.
I mean, even look what
I'm doing right now.
It's very meta, even
this downtime, I'm like,
"Fuck it, I'm gonna create
something signature",
"Tea With GaryVee," and then all of
it's gonna stream from
that, it's how I started
Wine Library TV, it's how, you
know my whole world is gone.
So, I think, look, you're
trying to build awareness
that you're good at something
or get known in a sector,
so let me explain how this works.
If you start up, you know a
fashion, if you started...
Let me go very niche here.
"Fashion In Social Weekly"
brought to you by
Lawrence Crookston, right?
Like, if that's the show, literally,
if you named it that show,
and then emailed and LinkedIn messaged 50
of the top fashion designers
in the world or fashion CEOs
or fashion creative directors, 50,
50, I'm talking top people,
you would be blown away.
You have nobody watching your
show, you would be blown away,
that two of them would
say yes to be a guest.
Now why that's important,
Lawrence is now all of a sudden,
you're on the phone for
35 minutes, 45 minutes
or in person for 45 minutes
with the Chief Creative
Officer of Stuart Weitzman.
And when you're done, that person's like,
"Thanks," like so, "What do you do?"
And you're like, "I'm actually a fashion."
You see where I'm going,
you're putting yourself
in a position to network
through bringing value.
That's how I think about it.
- Okay, so literally like, name it,
like "Fashion Weekly" with Lauren,
- Come up, yeah, come up with something,
you know, like this week
in fashion is very generic
but maybe this week in New
York Fashion is niche enough,
and so, you've limited
yourself to New York Fashion,
but at the same token, there's
fucking thousands of people
you need to meet in New York Fashion.
So you'll probably never get
to everybody in your pod.
You see where I'm going?
- Yeah, what I do is around
the New York Fashion Week,
I'll literally like, I work my day job
where I make coffees and
sandwiches and stuff.
So, I'll get up early in
the morning, hit up fashion,
we get on the streets and meet
like influencers and editors
and kind of build relationships like that,
and then go do my day job and then,
you know, go home and edit all the photos
and try to build those connections.
- I think hosting a podcast
around the industry,
that I mean, you call it
fashion photographer weekly.
You know, like, I like it going macro
because I want you to invite
the most important people
and get, once you get
five of them, two of them,
you can get anybody and all of a sudden
your podcast is why you're booking,
you know, more photography,
because you're letting them
talk about their business.
And it's like a good trade,
you're giving them a platform,
even though nobody's listening at first.
People still love giving interviews,
and what you're getting is awareness
and networking capabilities
that may lead to something.
- Okay.
- Awesome.
- Hey, I really appreciate
that, that's great advice.
- You got it, Lawrence.
- Hey, thank you.
- You got it brother, talk to you soon.
- Thanks.
- Thanks Lawrence.
Dallas Barnes just followed you,
thank you for sharing a screenshot.
If you're watching right now,
take a screenshot of this
and post it on your Twitter
and let everybody know
what you're watching
and I'm trying to get some
more people in here to watch
'cause it's super fun and I think
we're bringing in a lot of value
and I'm also looking to do
some fun stuff, so I see that.
Luke Churchill, here
has me, in his profile.
So I just like this, I
appreciate that Luke,
it was nice meeting you the other day.
Isabelle Stark, appreciate you watching,
thank you so much for that, I'm
really appreciative of that.
Dustin, I'm ready for next one.
- Hi, Ashley.
- Hey, Gary.
- How are you?
- Well, I'm super nervous, excited.
- Don't be nervous and just be excited,
so what can I help you with?
- Thank you, thank you
so much for having me.
Part of my thing was just doing this.
I've been--
- Good.
- Sort of hiding out for a while,
and what better way to--
- Break the ice?
- Yeah, where do you live?
- I used to do a lot of video
and I used to do a lot of lives
and went through some challenging times.
And then, now I work, I do
a lot with video right now,
but not in front of camera, so.
- Good for you, I'm glad you did it.
- Thank you, thank you for having me
and I'm just so incredibly
impressed with you
and your kindness, like
just listening to everything
that you're doing for everyone,
just all of these callers.
It's just such a true
act of just kindness.
And I just want to call that out first.
- Thank you for saying that.
- So, my thing is,
it's such an interesting
moment, I'm both oddly inspired
and excited and equally sad and you know,
holding the compassion in
my heart for what people
who are having hard moments,
are experiencing right now.
- I feel exactly the same way.
- And also at the same moment it's like
that excitement for truth.
- Yes, an opportunity
and truth and for pause,
you know pausing is powerful
and I think a lot of people
are gonna get in their
heads in a different way
and I do think gratitude
is gonna emerge for many
and I think cynicism for
others, a lot of people
who are insecure and who are cynical
are gonna be like "See
I just was on the verge
"of having it all figured out
"and then Corona came in."
This is a half glass empty,
half glass full moment, no question.
- Yeah, so for me, I was literally,
right before this was happening,
I was sort of re-looking at for myself,
sort of the opportunity
that presented itself
was, I have an eye for capturing video
and really understanding
like these nuggets
and these these Powerful two,
three minutes of content.
And, a couple of years ago,
I actually developed
a video business card.
And I created you know, I
had 50 people go through it
and, so it was called VidBits.
So, I was super excited and I was about
to sort of take flight and
then unfortunate my father
who was ill at the time,
it was time to go home
and be with him so that
that took precedence.
So when I got back from that,
it's like, I just couldn't--
- Get going.
- I couldn't, I couldn't do it.
- I get it.
- Trying to find myself
after many years of working for myself
in different businesses, like
"Okay, I guess I gotta go work
for someone else right now.
"I just don't have it in myself."
- And that's okay, I mean--
- And it was because it brought me
to some really interesting opportunities,
and I got to learn some new things--
- Good.
- Which has been great, and now I've,
you know, this year has been
great, I've been getting back.
And so, here I am now in this other place
with these sort of video nuggets
and these and I was like,
wow, I actually have a
business name VidBits.
And I'm talking about
small pieces of content
and actually have a team
that can create them.
So, it just started falling into place,
and I'm doing them currently
but then this happened and it's like,
well, you know, is it the
moment, is it the, you know,
just how I should show up in this moment?
How should I get to present myself--
- Yeah, I think, Ashley,
I think the biggest thing
is a relationship with time, right?
Like, you know, the reality is, if it is
or isn't the moment, I don't
view that as some huge,
if it's not the moment I don't view that
as some huge negative
because the reality is
within six months or 12
months, it might be the moment.
And of course, you know, we all
have to cherish every moment
we're on earth and you never
know what can happen tomorrow,
but knock on wood, there's a likely chance
that you've got a good 40 in you,
years, and I think you
know, when you actually
contextualize that, I think that's,
you know, your natural entrepreneurship
because you went that way, your
own time clock on ideology,
like should you be
working for somebody else
or should you not?
Your own ambition, an
ideology of like, who you are
and what you are and should
you be doing this or not?
The reality is, and this
is a very powerful answer,
it's funny, like how I
feel about this answer.
It doesn't matter.
Do you know, like me, what I mean by that,
and it's really powerful
and I'm starting to realize
why so much works for me,
whether I'm right or wrong,
whether it leads to the next great thing
or it literally becomes the seed
of my ultimate financial demise,
it really is all gonna be
okay, like think, what?
You know, like, and I mean it, I really,
I am very passionate
about perspectives, right?
To your point, going
through, did your dad pass?
- Yeah.
My mom's watching right now,
so shout out to her right now.
- Big shout out to mom, you know,
I'm sure your dad had lots of thoughts
about life the whole way
and then like ultimately
like what, right?
We just live and so, I
just wanna encourage you
to realize there is no wrong answer.
I mean that, I really believe that.
Because, I always tell people,
I'll give you a good example.
Somebody really in my inner circle
broke down with COVID, inner circle.
Solid acquaintance to maybe
borderline friend, right?
And you know, like a friend, a friend.
I was just right there,
I did it like, you know,
like really, like went
and I was talking to him
and I said something that really swung him
and I say it a lot if
you really follow me.
I don't say it that often
but if you follow me
you've heard this, I said,
"Look, bro, I get it."
But like, let's just
role play for a second,
let's take a step back and
reframe our perspective.
Let's say this didn't
happen, COVID didn't happen.
And, let's say you would
have gone to that pitch
that would have gotten you this money
that he's talking about,
like, let's just say
they even said yes, and then that say,
that you were happy and on the phone
and calling your wife after and saying,
you're getting the money and
you weren't paying attention,
and you literally, literally
got hit by fucking car
across the street in Chicago and died.
I'm like, you do understand
that that's possible.
You do understand that for all the deaths
that are gonna come from this disease,
there are gonna be handfuls hundreds,
if not thousands of
people around the world
who this actually saved their life,
because they wouldn't have
gone to that restaurant
and choked on that chicken bone.
Because, they wouldn't
have gotten on that flight
where they would have
gotten the radio activeness
that led to their cancer,
like I actually believe
that, Ashley, and I think, and
when I say it doesn't matter,
what I mean by that is we all do our best
in trying to make decisions.
But, if we actually realized the ones
that may seem like bad
decisions on paper upfront
actually led to being great
decision seven years later.
There's something that I'm able to do
through my DNA upbringing and perspective
and now practice and is just realizing
you got to give things time to figure out
if they were right or
wrong, and everybody,
like, wants to judge everything so short.
You see what I mean?
- Yeah, now I totally
get that, and I really,
I feel like I've learned to
practice that more and more,
especially in the last
couple years, just--
- Good.
- You know, that patience.
- Yeah, and gratitude, right?
Even pretty, I mean--
- Every day.
- Everyone's like, this sucks,
I'm like, you and I are talking right now,
because of modern technology.
If this happened in
1987, like that you know,
we would have missed out on
a ton of human interaction
that really, right now
people are getting their fix
on human interaction,
look what we're doing.
I'll give you one, Ash.
I'll give you a one, let's go very meta.
I might have said
something in the right way
at the right moment to you
now that will bring you value.
There's no fucking way I'm
doing "Tea With GaryVee",
if there was no COVID, I'd
be in a meeting, right?
- Completely.
- Right, we need to understand that life
is unbelievably complex and layered.
And we need to lean into
optimism and gratitude
and whether it's time for bits or not.
I just think that you should think
that every decision is right.
And I think most people think
every decision is wrong.
Like most people just go into like,
"Did I make the right decision?"
There's just this unbelievable
ability to beat oneself up
to be cynical, to be
pessimistic, to be fear based.
And I'm just trying to
get people to flip it
because life is actually how
it plays out in your head.
It just actually is.
My ability to turn every
negative into a positive
is very real.
And I watched many people taking positives
and turning it to negatives.
It's very real.
Life is a perspective game
and we need to have more
positive optimism, the end.
- 100%, I couldn't agree more.
- I love it.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- I wish you the best.
Take care, Ash, bye, bye.
- Appreciate your time
and this has just--
- Bye, mom.
- Been an incredible experience
just watching this every morning.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much, take care.
Man, that was fun.
I really believe in that shit,
really, really, really do.
Rock Dance Theater, thank
you so much for sharing.
Mike Turner, thank you "Tea With GaryVee".
You get a follow.
And Mike Turner, I'm gonna
reply to you right now.
Do you drink wine?
This is me asking you
because then I wanna tell you
to sign up for winetext.com.
If you're watching right now,
and if you've gotten value out of these,
you know, "Tea With GaryVees"
and you drink wine, winetext.com, Bianca.
- Hi.
- Hi, how are you?
- Oh my gosh, I'm good, I'm so excited!
I've been up since 5:00 a.m. my time,
hoping to be on.
- You're amazing, are you--
- I'm from Seattle.
Seattle, west coast, how are you?
- Yes, I'm good.
So, my question is,
obviously for the first time
I'm laid off and all
of the not enough time
problems have kind of gone away.
But, it's also been a
little bit paralyzing.
Because now I'm like
I have all these ideas
and I'm like, don't
know where to go first.
So I've kind of narrowed
it down to two main ideas.
I'm a dance teacher and I have this idea
of like an online dance
program for beginners.
But, my kind of where my heart wants to go
is more into like a coaching business.
Last summer, I did a leadership program,
it kind of just shifted my whole world
and so, I got a lot of practice
and experience coaching
and I would love to just--
- Bianca, I'm gonna give you
a direct tangible prescription
because it's so obvious to me, you ready?
- Yes.
- I would like you to do something,
I want you to start a Facebook group.
And I want you to start a Zoom
session, and literally spam.
And I'm using spam as
kind of like a slang term.
I want you to post on your
Facebook and your Instagram,
that you're going on zoom,
and you are inviting people.
And if you'd like to come on
and just shoot the shit with me,
we're gonna talk about leadership
and thought and mindset.
I want you to go, I want
you to go into action.
I want you to go directly
into doing what I'm doing with
"Tea With GaryVee", but I want
you to do in a group setting.
I want you to get five,
10, 15 people into a Zoom,
and literally just shoot
the shit or a Google Hangout
or whatever works for you.
So, I literally want
you to start doing it.
You have a hypothesis in your heart,
like just go and just shoot the
shit about life or whatever.
I also need you, desperately
to make to dance videos
on TikTok every single day.
- I had a feeling you're gonna say that.
- Bianca I'm telling you, it's very real.
What people don't like,
as you were thinking,
people are crippled by, I have 10 ideas.
People are crippled by I've
narrowed it down to two,
which one's the right one?
And what people don't understand
is in today's internet,
the answer is yes.
And both and the answer is "and" like,
literally, by this afternoon,
in seven hours, in 10 hours,
you should have two TikTok dance videos.
And in your profile,
it should say dance
teacher with your email.
And at six o'clock at night tonight,
you know, which would be
nine on the East Coast,
you should be doing a little wine,
happy hour leadership mindset,
like kind of little jam session
that you're the fucking queen
bee of that you're leading.
Here's the topic, here's the questions.
And literally in 24 hours,
you've now started the process
of figuring out the right
answer through action.
Not through debate.
- Got it, yeah.
So you you would suggest
just like getting a group
of people on Facebook
is what I'm hearing
and then coming up with kind
of like a format beforehand
and just like some questions
maybe to throw out or?
- Yeah.
- I get lost in the
mechanics of it, you know?
- Yeah, I'm gonna get you un-mechaniced,
get seven to 10 people
into a Google Hangout
'cause I want them to
be physically on there.
Post on your Facebook,
post on your Instagram,
email your entire
address book and be like,
"I'm doing a leadership,
a free leadership seminar.
"I know a lot of us are bored,
"I'm getting on FaceTime,
grab your cup of coffee,
"grab a glass of wine."
And then when you get there, just talk.
- Okay.
- I mean, it's very
easy, the first one like,
"How's everybody?"
Literally, you're like,
"How's everybody getting through this?"
That's a good starting
point, you know what I mean?
And then tell everybody why you're,
I mean, literally be
like, "Hey, nine hours ago
"Gary Vee was yelling at me
"on "Tea With GaryVee" to do this,
"that's why it's happening."
And then tell them what
happened a year ago,
how much you loved it
and why you're doing it.
Just start shooting the shit, conversate.
- Okay.
- Listen to me, making and
doing is the only answer
and everybody plays life in their head,
and I want everybody to
play their life in life.
- I love it, I love it.
- Because, both of your good
debates, you're gonna have,
if you do what I just said to you,
every day for two weeks here,
you're gonna have a much
better feel of which one.
What if it was actually dancing
and it was about TikTok explosion
and getting virtual dance classes
and getting rates that you
never could have imagined
and maybe you loved it more?
And maybe in that dance class
you do do some leadership
and mindset and life
coaching and they like,
so, you gotta do to, you
gotta taste, you gotta try,
you gotta make, you gotta do,
and everyone just sits in the
room and thinks and ponders.
- Yes, totally relatable, yeah.
- Everybody ponders and I
want everybody to play, right?
I want everybody to play,
do more playing, less pondering, right?
- Yeah, yeah, no, I love your suggestion
because, I get kind of
lost in that details.
I don't always connect like
the way to just get out there
and try something because I get so lost
in the non-important steps.
- Because most people are insecure
and think they need to
have it right to do it.
It's the manifestation of insecurity.
- Right, well and I'm really,
I really appreciate your work
because you've definitely
helped me shift out of that.
- Good, let's do more.
- Like, I'm definitely more
willing to just like post things
and just kind of see if
people like it or not?
And so I really, really--
- Because, their opinions
don't matter, like fuck them.
If they say you suck, fuck them.
- Fully.
- It's true, it's true, it's true, like
okay cool, sorry, Randy, the mailman,
you think I'm an idiot, cool.
Like sorry, Aunt June,
"I'm sorry Aunt June
"that you think this is silly,
"you go worry about your fucking cat."
You know, like, you know
what I mean, like what?
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, thank you so much.
- You're welcome, take care.
All right, getting towards the end
of another episode of "Tea With GaryVee",
Valerie is in the building.
Hey, Val?
- Hi.
- How are you?
- I'm good, can you hear me?
- I can.
- Awesome, I'm also from Seattle,
So, I feel like I'm--
- I love it.
- Okay, yeah, this is
so great that we have
this opportunity, like our grandparents
would never have been
able to do this, right?
So, I'm just loving this right now,
you're providing so
much value to everyone,
and I just, I'm super stoked, so.
- Thank you
- Yeah,
I have been listening to
you and been really inspired
and my passion kind of
similar actually, to Bianca,
I work in the corporate world
and nonprofit healthcare.
And I would love to kind of
get in the space of being
like a consultant for different businesses
and employee engagement like
via positive psychology.
So similar question,
how would you do that?
Like how would you begin to
scale that obviously LinkedIn
is like my game right now,
but I'm a little concerned
of like posting on there,
just because I'm currently,
I don't work--
- Employed.
- So, I--
- So I think, but I actually
think you can get away with it,
and the way you do that is by making it
as general thought sharing,
more so than hire me to do this.
You're just building your awareness,
and you're just sharing your
thoughts on these issues.
You're almost--
- Yes,
- You're almost journaling, you
know, you're almost sharing.
- Okay, and that's not like
threatening to my current--
- It maybe, it may be, it may be.
- So you see,
- I do, I do, the problem is,
then you're out of options, right?
Like the way to do it
is one of a couple ways.
One, the way to actually build up demand
is through creating the content
that leads to awareness,
to your point, if that's
detrimental to your org.
Look, the reality is is that most,
if you can make it general enough,
most orgs, most companies have
a very unique relationship
with their employees, unfortunately,
most companies wanna keep
their employees in jail.
I, on the other hand, am desperate
to build up the profiles of my employees,
James Rossini, Nick Deon,
Claude silver, De ROC,
like I want them to
build up their profiles,
because I think that's karma,
and the world is abundant.
And if they feel that they can do better
outside of my four walls,
I want that for them.
I don't want to suppress them.
I have empathy, that that
might not be the case
for your situation, but
I think the more general
and non-threatening you go, if you're not
asking for business, then
you're just building awareness
around the subject matter,
and then if they're
just super cynical, then you
may have to deal with that.
- Right, so I guess a
follow up question for you,
is how do we get more
leaders to be influential
in a way that you are?
How do we incorporate more positivity?
And you know, the leadership
that you bring to the
team, in your opinion?
- I think we find the ones
that are naturally are in it
because a lot of people aren't,
many leaders lead with fear.
And I don't think we're
gonna be able to change,
I don't think we'd be able
to change them overnight.
I think we can have
the ball down the field
and have them debate.
But I think the way we do
it is actually triple down
on the people that have naturally in them
and build awareness towards that, right?
Like, for example, I think
there's a lot of 24 year olds
who had it in them, who
because they now look up to me
will do more of it, than they
would have had I not existed
and I feel like that's a
legacy that I'm proud of.
- Right, right.
So kind of capitalize
on those ones that are
the rising stars or that
are doing it already,
and just go big on that, okay.
- That's right Val, because
most people's intuition
is to try to change the
person who is the leader,
but too much parenting, too
much DNA, too much culture,
too much old dogs new tricks.
You can get them from
being a zero to a three
on the positivity and
opposite, you know, thing.
Whereas, but that would take years,
whereas, you could take somebody
from a natural four to a 10
by just giving them encouragement.
- Okay, and then should
I also be posting on,
I mean, obviously other platforms as well,
but do you have other techniques
to kind of get myself out there?
Content creation, obviously.
- You know, it's so funny, Val.
It is content creation,
is it doing a podcast
where you start by
interviewing all the bosses
in your own company, which maybe--
- I have started doing that already.
- I'm proud of you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, what I don't
think people understand is,
I say this a lot, I think I can tell that
you're paying attention.
It is like exercise, and eating well.
The formula to being in shape
is actually remarkably scary simple.
The discipline to execute is
hard, my model is very simple.
I think you should produce content
on every single platform in the world,
and I think that you should
do it every single day.
And every waking hour,
and when you do a podcast
that it should be recorded
and post produced,
it's why I put out those decks,
those, you know, slides--
- Yes, I love those.
- You know, for anybody who doesn't know
what I'm talking about,
just search GaryVee deck
or GaryVee content model
on Google, you'll find it.
The formula is real, the
discipline to do it is hard.
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
I appreciate you so much and the world--
- I appreciate you more.
- So much right now, so thank
you, I love your content.
- Thank you, Val.
Seattle back to back, I
like that, I like that.
- Cody, what's good?
- What's up, Gary?
- Life is good, you?
- Hanging in there,
getting into online classes
and getting adapting to that.
- It is definitely an intense variable.
Is it, are you like enjoying
it or is it like suck?
- There's one class that
is a little difficult
to kind of understand but he's kind of
splitting it up into different sections
trying to get simpler.
And then everything else seems to be
smooth sailing right now,
I'm actually using Zoom.
I've never used Zoom
before until this semester,
so, I was glad to get to know
it, now look where I'm at.
I get to use it and talk to you.
- Awesome, what can I
help you with, brother?
- Yeah, so in the recent years,
I know that you have emphasized
on looking up like your,
where you live on Instagram
and seeing the top five posts
and interacting with them.
The promise with my area I live
in Iowa, Cedar Rapids, Iowa.
And my posts don't really consist
of like, creating content.
It's like really random posts,
I don't really know how to describe them,
so what do you suggest I do?
- Well, what are you trying to accomplish?
- I would like to get
myself out there to be,
I am studying to be an
information technologists
in the computers support
specialist degree.
But, I also like to do
videography, so I was thinking
if I put myself out
there with making videos,
I could help people around
my town make a video.
- I understand.
- Yeah, for their businesses,
or whatever it is they do.
- So, I think you should put
out videos on your account.
- Hmm.
- And then I think you
should DM all the businesses
that have an Instagram
account in your area.
And you should give them a pointer or two.
Don't tell them that you
could do videos for free.
I mean, you can say
I'll do videos for free
'cause I think that would
work to some of them,
but I, you definitely shouldn't say
"Hey, why don't you hire me
"to make a video, you need a video?
- Yeah.
- What you should do is
say, let's role play,
I'll write the email,
"Dear, Iowa Steel Curtains.
"Iowa Curtains, hope all
is well, just stumbled
"on your Instagram account,
I know a little bit
"about content and social.
"I noticed on your Instagram account",
this is the DM you're writing them, Cody,
"I noticed on your Instagram account,
"you didn't link your website
in your Instagram profile,
"you should definitely do that
"because anybody that
sees one of your photos
"will then click to
it, that's very basic."
They might, I would assume 90%
of people will have their URL there,
but that would be example, you could say,
"Dear Iowa Fried Chicken,
hope all is well,
"hope you're doing well with this COVID.
"Hope your business is okay.
"I'm Cody, I happen to
know a lot about content
"and social, I stumbled on your page.
"And I happen to notice that you do get
"30 to 40 comments per post,
"but, I look back in the
last year of your content
"and you've never replied to anybody.
"If you reply you'll build
a much stronger community
"which will probably help
you sell a lot of chicken.
"Also I noticed you've
done a lot of pictures.
"You should start mixing in some video."
If Cody, if you do that, if you make,
if you put out content on your profile,
and you go DM businesses in your area,
if your hope is to get them
to hire you to do videos for them,
but you don't sell to
them, but you provide them
a free five minute social
media audit and DM them.
I guarantee three of them,
if you DM 50 people a week,
100 people a week, I
guarantee three of them
will become clients of yours,
I really believe in that.
- Got it, awesome.
- Understood?
- Yep, awesome.
- Awesome, man.
Good luck, talk to you soon.
- Yep, thanks, Gary.
- All right, I gotta steal three minutes
back for prepping for
this 11:00 a.m. call.
So this was another episode
of "Tea with GaryVee."
I hope you guys can join me
tomorrow at 9:00 a.m. Eastern.
Tell all your West Coast
friends to wake up at 5:45,
would love a barrage of feedback
on today's episode on Twitter.
My team is going to be chopping this up,
it would mean a lot to me.
If you went to Twitter right now and said
what your favorite part was,
it might lead to some
observations for me and the team
and it would show me all
the faces and accounts
that I've been watching this morning.
So please go to Twitter
GaryVee is my Twitter handle.
If you don't have a Twitter account,
and you're watching this,
please set up a Twitter account.
Go to Twitter right now and
set up a Twitter account,
You need a Twitter account period.
And that's that so wish you well,
I can't wait to see you tomorrow.
I love you guys, hope you enjoyed.
Dustin, thank you so much
for your help on the ones and twos.
- [Dustin] My pleasure.
- And we will talk to everybody
soon, bye bye everyone.